it's time for screen junkies boobie
bytes what's that who's there oh hey
welcome to movie fights everybody we are
gonna throw down with some cinematic
queries and we have a trio of cinematic
experts to answer these questions some
or all of that may be varying degrees of
true and false but way it's a really fun
group of fighters here today what do you
say we meet them
this guy Oh hashtag Botanica what a
weirdo
what a weird guy with your answer yeah
but he also knows a lot about movies a
big fan he's a very funny man Mike
Carlson thank you I am a cinematic
expert also so that is accurate but you
got beaten by a puppet the last time yes
I built it friend sometimes you when you
love something like puppets so much and
you're in the room with them you get
overwhelmed and you get maybe like
you're not on your game because you're
so starstruck so I was in the room with
puppets I feel that you know not my best
performance but I'm willing to take the
puppets on again and I feel that there
will be a different outcome this time
yeah I mean the same thing happened to
me when I got face to face with Miss
Mariah Carey Morris of course who
wouldn't when you made me me right yes
what is their name Mimi you uh know her
from all over the place and she's a good
friend of the family and a new mom and
oh baby Luna is adorable welcome back to
the show Sasha pearl raver I am a
cinematic query I'm very excited astok I
think that uh I was terrified when I
found out Carlson was here we know how
he plays yep fast and weird fast weird
dirty and and I totally understand the
puppet thing because that was honestly
one of the greatest fights of ever seen
in my life I'm sorry that you lost it
but blaze of glory did blaze of glory
yep and Jovi that cucumber was it real
he was a real tough one here okay yeah
to crack I agree and this gentleman oh
well he he's making a long way to return
to the screen junkies fold he used to be
on the screen junkies show back in the
day pretty on the Reg
and he's a super funny guy you know him
from many writing assignments and
projects my first grade book report oh
yeah a Badge of Courage and the good
mythical morning Cartoon Network Funny
or Die and he's the co-host of the super
funny
Jordan Jessie go podcast Jordan Morris
hey everybody I probably mentioned up
top here elephant in the room I actually
am a puppet I am one of those I've liked
the Swedish Chef oh my human hands she's
controlling my mouth and these are
puppeteers hands I was wondering why
there was a hand up your butt actually
unrelated three great fighters and to
help us break down these decisions it's
going to be myself and we have the Dan
cam hold it down the facts Dan Morrell
Dan what is new in the world how's your
long-running feud with the people the
god Eamon Gotti well the audience score
tipped over to Rotten so I don't know
they don't know who you people should
believe yeah I don't know they went
quiet yeah like they they they they
started they came at me and then I kind
of said some words back and I never
answered so did you have to leave squash
versus head and anyone's bed no no
comment okay noted thank you dan Merle
and the voice of the people the conduit
of the Internet the delightful Daniel
Radford hi so first of all being
overwhelmed by Celtic friends I don't
know what that feels like I don't know I
don't know what that would even look
like losing it that video to the
Danielle it was the purest most
wonderful thing we've seen in 2018 fake
news so the way that this works is that
yes I am the voice of you and so there
is a pole that is on YouTube there are
many really fun poles on Twitter please
join them please have fun please go into
the hashtag movie fads
movie that's movie fights live because I
am going to be in that hashtag looking
at all of your all of your memes
all of the tweets any kind of like fun
asides or anything you have I will be
looking at those but also as in the
YouTube poll when there is a tie
we are the tiebreaker my dudes so vote
in those polls if you're unsure about
how to you can go down to the
description below you can ask us in the
chat there are many wonderful admins who
are ready to help assist you but just
know that if you're asking us while
everyone is going through their first
answers of the round we're not going to
put it up until everyone has had a
chance to do their opening arguments
because we want this to be not about the
movies but about the arguments because
that is what this show is about hell
yeah what she said
yeah also before we jump into the fun
Danielle I wanted to point out that you
and Jordan are both working on a little
project together a new podcast Jordan
would you mind giving us kind of just a
thumbnail of what that is yeah sure and
maybe Danielle feel free to chime in if
you think I've left anything out yeah
there's a new podcast on the maximum fun
Network called bubble it's 8 episodes
it's it's it's a fictional it's a sci-fi
comedy notice how you said fictional
like it was a selling point yeah usually
doesn't do fictional we do a lot of like
interviews and feelings and how does
Daniel feel about wrestling yeah it's
mostly Daniels wrestling feelings but
this is a it's a sci-fi comedy
miniseries I think if yeah it's maybe a
little mash up it's a little Buffy the
Vampire Slayer
it's a little Portlandia it's a little
Logan's Run yeah if you like a classic
sci-fi Daniel does some of the voices I
did some of the writing on the show tons
of funny people Alison Becker from Parks
and Rec yeah Stella Alonso from cars 3
from 30 rock Mike Mitchell from the
doughboys podcast yeah a lot of cool
people in it so yeah if you wanna if you
want to take a little dip into the world
of fiction yeah it's bubble it's like an
old time radio play kind of there are
there aren't as many boxes filled with
hammers being shaken some you buy your
boxes filled with hammers shaken noises
now online yeah yeah exactly
- soundboard yeah one thing I will say
is like this is one of those projects
where if I wasn't on it
I would be like why am nine not on this
yeah you describe that Jordan it's like
oh those are a bunch of things that I
like and much of our audience like so I
want to listen to the to the words on
that podcast I want to listen to it yes
yes yes you should listen to it and the
audience should listen to it bubble on
the maximum fund network that's it
heck yes Jordan Thank You Danielle thank
you for everything and just one more
quick breakdown we have three fighters
seven questions the first one to four
points wins three regular round
questions then we go into the speed
round
someone give me down three Oh going into
the speed around and it's still
anybody's game because you can catch up
and overtake them in the speed round
that's about it jte drop that sick-ass
package
[Music]
[Applause]
JT best package in the biz alright
question number one oh hey NBA fans
uncle Drew is opening this weekend Kyrie
Irving in the gang what is the best
performance ever given by a professional
athlete what is the best performance
ever given by a professional athlete we
are going to start with Mike Carlson all
right now my professional athlete comes
from the greatest sport on earth
professional wrestling that's my
favorite but it's also I think we can
all agree the best not baseball not
basketball professional wrestling Thank
You Danielle and that's why I did that I
was pandering to you Andre the Giant in
the Princess Bride
okay now we're not talking about a
flashy performance we're not talking
about someone who's trying to act like a
tough guy we're talking about a soulful
performance something that is
understated you think wrestler you think
oh it's gonna be some puffs chest kind
of I'm angry no no it's under the Giant
you see that this man has heart he has
size he has presence it is amazing what
he does in this movie you remember this
performance almost more than a movie
full of great performances full of great
character actors I think that this is
something that takes Andre the Giant you
know him from the ring now you see this
extra dimension to him he has enacted
and a lot of stuff and he blows everyone
away in this performance I think it's
incredible I think it's the best
performance by an athlete in any film
Mike do you mean it I of course mean it
I'm I was setting you up for anybody
want a peanut come on oh I am a little
I'm sorry I'm sleepy today I alright did
you get what I was doing I didn't I
didn't get that Mike Carlson with Andre
the Giant anybody want a peanut sauce
your pro raver who you got I have I mean
one of the greatest people working in
film today Dwayne the rock Johnson
ladies and gentlemen I cannot tell you
how excited I am for skyscraper but
before we even get to that let's talk
about his performance as Hobbs in the
entire Fast and Furious franchise but
we're going straight to Fast Five
because you my name Dwayne the rock
Johnson and Daniel King giggle but
performance at rest
BRAC did this franchise and mike if
you're gonna talk about greatest sports
yes he comes through the greatest sport
wrestling he is what you smell when you
are cooking because sort of the rock but
when you talk about action when you talk
about charisma when you talk about
presence when you talk about sheer mass
you can only talk about the rock and he
brought what you needed you talk about a
great performance his physicality is
what made those action sequences so
fantastic and people had given up on the
Fast and Furious until the rock which is
why now he and Statham are going off to
do their own thing I am here for it I'm
getting sweaty just thinking about it
because it's not good all right Sasha
Pro raver with the rock in Fast Five
Jordan Morris there's an Olympic athlete
named Kurt Thomas and he starred in a
very underrated but deservedly cult
classic film gymkata gymkata is a
martial art that combines gymnastic
skills with karate kills 80s action
movie starring a gymnast
he plays ace he plays a gymnast who is
also a secret agent who goes to the
fictional country of Parma Stan to in a
deadly game and he uses a martial art
that he created himself that is a that
mixes gymnastic skills and karate kills
it is truly amazing it's a very corny
movie in the kind of vein of kickboxer
or bloodsport or one of those kind of
you know eighties late-night movie
classics but the things he is doing in
this are genuinely amazing there is a
scene where he's running through the
village of the crazies okay is that what
it's called me yes is called the village
of the crazies and it's a and he's
running from the villagers and he runs
into a town square where there is just a
pommel horse for no reason and he uses
that pommel horse to kick everyone's ass
it's totally amazing and as I think we
got a glimpse of in that still he does
all of this in pleated slacks and
sweaters Wow all right find it out
everybody all right first things first
crimes go ahead name me a line that is
definitive from Andre the Giant
in the Princess Bride the peanut one
that Jordan says you didn't remember it
so that automatically knocks it out when
people talk about the Princess Bride
it's like marriage and as you wish
I love Andre the Giant but if you watch
the documentary that's on HBO right now
he says specifically Reiner and Billy
Crystal he wasn't acting it was him that
was literally he showed up he was
gigantic and that's just him as a
personality they couldn't get him to act
but it is hard to act like yourself
that's not that's a thing to do to bring
completely yourself to the screen that
is not something everyone can do the
rock is the rock in the Fast and Furious
movies though right
but that performance that's a cultivated
personality if you watch him on social
media in any movie he does yes you are
always buying the rock but that is the
magnetism that you pay for it that's
probably not the duty is behind the
scenes you think that's the guy he is
when he goes home he takes a poll he's
all ego he does not have a performance
where he can show you who he is he's
always puffing out his chest and looking
cool I think he has it in his contract
that he cannot look uncool he's very
self-conscious he does look cool but
that is I'm wanting something more
layered something with a different
deeper you've got a gymnastic skills and
karate kills I will say so so here's
here's where I think gymkata comes out
ahead it he is using the thing he was
made famous for he is doing amazing
gymnastics fees kicking fools in the
head in this movie if he's just standing
having a conversation he'll just do a
flip and it's totally amazing and I
think that you know while the rock does
some impressive fighting in the FF
franchise which is a favorite of mine
it's it's mostly driving it's mostly
one-liners it's mostly flexing his way
out of a cast which I love one of my
quintessential best moments thank you
it's an amazing moment it's an amazing
movie moment when he flexes himself and
says daddy's got to go to work but is he
really it's great it's great for me is
he doing is he using what he was made
famous for not really absolutely in the
first scene that you see him in what
they're doing it's hand-to-hand combat
where you're doing staged fighting
you're saying this movie is great
because I'm sorry what's his name Kurt
or comments
yes even Olympic using gold venomous
he's not famous I never heard of him
until I googled the gymkata yeah which I
will say the trailer is impressive it's
a wonderful movie and yeah but I think
this is if we're talking about you know
I think the rock at this point is more
of a performer and we're talking about
athletes and this man is performances
what's the best performance what is the
best performance ever given by a
professional athlete he's a performer as
you just said there is nobody who has
created more of a persona in a better
way right now than the rock and what he
did think about the egos he's contending
with in the Fast and Furious movies
think about the things he has to go up
against a safe driving through Rio
taking out cars as he goes and you know
what still the best part of that movie
of the rock but where is the paint those
warnings go ahead where you actually
worried the rock when do you actually
feel for him you go this is the Superman
character he's not gonna lose he's gonna
win every movie he's ever he's barely
put in a bad situation is at the end of
Fast Five he'll a good man get away he
doesn't actually doesn't get up he
doesn't like look stupid he just looked
lets a guy get away it's completely
equal the entire time because that was
contractual only way you can tell who's
who is because he has a goatee and the
other one doesn't but still you when
we're talking about performances like
we're talking about acting Andre the
Giant didn't act he just showed up got
super drunk said his lines and they said
it was very difficult because they
couldn't understand what he was a man
he's drunk and performing like that that
is pretty mr. Marlon Brando opera let me
go back to the rock yes I think he's
contractually obligated to perform all
of his scenes in Under Armor yes and
this is tactical we're made for athletes
at me for athletes but also could you
not argue that it's more impressive to
do amazing fight scenes dressed like a
high school science teacher like mr.
Kurt Thomas doesn't gymkata wearing
Christmas sweaters wearing pleated
slacks you look like a dad on his way to
a Jimmy Buffett concert but that's how I
give that's that sounds close
he's it's like when the when the flash
needs to run less fast and he puts on an
iron boot Kurt Thomas is impeding
himself by wearing you know something
for his family Christmas and also we
don't have confirmation in wrestling
Dean Ambrose wrestles and jeans okay but
they're not actually jeans they're
tights that are made to look like jeans
we don't know what the material he's
bring the costume person in from Jim cot
about a minute dot-ne eyes are crossed
any outstanding tees y'all about a
minute left I just have to say I feel
like the rock could be celebrated for so
many things but Hobbs is truly the
performance that we will watch in the
decades to come because it was so
profound it did so much for cinema and
it brought his star to a different level
and it brought that franchise to another
level and we have him to thank for it
this thing is kind of bad in moaña sorry
I'm just taking cheap shots now cuz I
don't I feel like I'm losing and I'm
panicking now listen I just think if
we're celebrating athletes and we're
celebrating athletics not action stars
not supermen which these these people
you mentioned clearly are I think we
need to to to celebrate a man who went
out of his comfort zone who was clearly
bad at acting and uncomfortable on
camera who did his best to do a lot of
flips and kick ninjas using the skills
he learned as an Olympic gymnast a gold
medalist time alright there we have it
Wow I didn't really get a last word oh
you know what I said there's about a
minute left any oh never mind you mean
it I'll give you a last word
gymnastics is not as good as wrestling
there you go
now time can't argue with that yeah okay
you know what my mom would argue with
that while watching the Olympics and
Murrell fact just a few as Danielle
pointed out to me there was a line of
Chuck Norris action jeans made in the
1980s basically it's a close-up of his
crotch doing a kick so it's just saying
that these were made for action so there
has been a action apparel line I'm
talking about pleated slacks that's true
I should say an action pant has been
made the rock flexing out of the cast is
from giving a 7.5 so I'm gonna have to
take that into consideration Kurt Thomas
he was a member of the u.s. Olympic team
in 1976 but did not medal in the
Olympics he is a three-time gold
medalist in the World Championships and
he was considered to be a favourite for
the games in 1980 but the u.s. boycotted
those games so he didn't go he never
returned to the Olympics but he is an
Olympian gotcha
and now it sure false Dan after he got
him to acting he ended up taking home
the e got yes Kurt Thomas and Whoopi
Goldberg great so this three interesting
performances Mike Carlson Sascha came at
you hard with all that info from the HBO
Andre the Giant documentary and you
pretty much just concurred with her but
tried to say yeah that's good that he
did that yeah so I'm gonna give you
third place unless and this one here and
came down to Jordan and Sasha for me
Jordan
you like really painted a great picture
for this guy and the performing in that
kind of outfit I love that there was a
town called village of the crazies I
actually like would I want to see Jim
cotton now and maybe have some sort of
drinking game around it or the watch
it's worth a watch every time he gets on
a pommel horse yeah every time there's a
piece of gymnastics equipment place
Town Square where there's a fight going
that sounds amazing so an uneven bars
part anyway go ahead love it
but um Sasha really spelled out to me
how the rock not just stepped up The
Fast and the Furious franchise but also
his career standing with his turn in
Fast Five and you pretty much started
singing the praises of the rock and last
Friday so the roughest and Sasha well I
would have picked Hulk Hogan for his
classic suburban commando but that's
just yeah second choice was the
Undertaker in suburban man Ramsay I
incur with you how I just didn't really
hear enough about Andre the Giant I felt
like there were too many negatives
brought up and and if the question was
which movie do I want to see right now
than its Jordans hands down I goodnight
now very much want to see gymkata but
the argument at hand in the question
hand I have to agree that Sasha made in
the most compelling case
Detroit awesome internet right the
internet says 50% Andre the Giant The
Princess Bride
34% The Rock Fast Five 15% Kirk Thomas
Gymkhana I will thing this feels like
the most Danielle radford and every part
of me is very happy about it
where are the other answers out there
yes more people just pandering to Daniel
Radford at jpg John Cena John Cena
Andy Johnson blockers dancing best
wrestler turned actor is Dave Bautista
and guardians we down
in a writer in 2149 oh and this one is a
so jr ass pit boy 2008 y'all know him as
Jack Shipley said okay I dropped
everything I'm gonna wah the answer is
Michael Jordan and spacejam and you all
know it's Jax fair the Monstars right on
um I'll break up a classic one one of
the greatest NFL running backs of all
time Jim Brown in the Dirty Dozen which
if you haven't seen the class-action 30
dozen with Lee Marvin and all-star cast
check that out and of course I have to
say for jte obviously Carl Weathers I'd
also like to endorse Lee Trevino and
happy gilmore we could keep going all
day long
[Applause]
wait John Cena John Cena yeah all right
so after one round at Sasha won Jordan
and Mike goose eggs all right
so here's a question for you question
number two who watches the Watchmen are
you gonna watch The Watchmen there's
been quite a bit of news this week about
HBO's The Watchmen and the current there
and the remake and the casting we have
asked our movie fight combatants to
recast the Watchmen so this round is
gonna work a little bit differently we
are going to throw out a watchman
character and then go around and hear
their individual choices let them debate
those choices for a minute or so and
then we are going to weigh in on each of
their choices at the end of those six
character choices we'll see who has
racked up the most victories as far as
their individual character choices that
person will take the point so again
we'll hear their arguments for six
characters will weigh in on whose choice
for each of the six was correct and
whoever has them most accumulated they
take the one point for this round make a
little bit of sense yes all right let's
jump into the fun
and Sasha we're going to start with you
for this recast the character Ozymandias
I feel like this was the easiest answer
I've ever had which is army hammer so
easy when you talk about this character
you want to think about the pinnacle of
physical beauty somebody who's glamorous
sophisticated lethally cool and have you
guys seen army hammer in a tracksuit
he's supposed to be sort of European
descent he looks very Arian nation in
the comic I mean it's just 100% him in
terms of like that physicality and
somebody who is so starkly white and yet
so intensely alluring alright armie
hammer Jordan who do you have I am going
Donald Glover one of the things I love
about this character is the you know is
the confidence and I think that's kind
of what even spoiler alert for this 30
year old graphic novel at this point but
he has the kind of the villain his his
you know his cornerstone is that he
thinks he knows what is best for the
world and I think something that Donald
Glover does so well and everything is to
be kind of a cocksure confident guy but
you don't hate him and I think with
Ozymandias obviously like him kind of
manipulating PR is a big thing so he has
to be confident but you can't hate him
and I think that is what Donald Glover
does so well that's what he did great in
solo in community he was kind of a
confident guy who said stupid things and
you still liked him and I think that is
kind of what he does well I mean
obviously there's maybe some age
problems I mean I don't know what
Lindelof is doing timeline-wise
so maybe it would have to be he's a boy
genius or something like that but I
think Donald Glover is choice great Mike
I'm gonna pick something a choice that's
very controversial I think the
confidence that Jordan was bringing up
is very important and there's no more
hateable confident person than YouTube
star Logan Paul Wow okay this is a man
who is handsome and fits well sure maybe
symmetrically handsome I'm not saying
I'm attracted to me because I certainly
am NOT because you know he's terrible
but this is a controversial choice I
think that you're going to not you're
not only going to just dislike this
character you're gonna feel it
because you know the actor behind it is
terrible as I said before I think that
this is a the watchman is a disgust not
disgusting but a very grim story about
reagan-era politics and I think no one
is going to play the villain better than
like terrible libertarian YouTube star
Logan Paul one follow-up question Mike
yeah go ahead
you trolling me right now never okay
never told on the show in my life
all right there are the three answers so
let's go to Daniel Radford Danielle who
do you like out of that one okay yeah so
as all of y'all know there's no it's
just opinions there's no just opinions
right now no you know uh you tube polls
so I'm just gonna give my guess hmm I
feel like as much as I love you Carlson
there is a strong argument for you to
have picked Logan Paul and you didn't
pick it and it was the one about media
manipulation yes sure sure sure
being able to get people on your side
and the era of YouTube and all of these
things Donald Glover is a fantastic
choice Jordan um with the confidence and
the [ __ ] sure you don't hate him because
of manipulation but ultimately I had to
go with the army hammer me hammer he is
so charming and I will say that like I
have seen him in roles where he has been
an absolutely terrible person but I have
wanted to listen to him more and also yo
when I saw him in social network I was
like why aren't there actually two of
them dan burrows do you like I I agree
Logan Paul is an interesting choice but
not my personal thing it was between
Jordan and Sasha and I have to agree
with Danielle that armie hammer just
seemed like the best fit given both of
their arguments I am also going to go
with armie hammer great all right Sasha
you look and you take that one next up a
cast night owl to night owl - let's
start with Jordan on this one so my
choice r9l - is Tom Cruise something so
I think the night has something I think
we would all like to see Tom Cruise do
is to play his age I think Tom Cruise
something that he is doing now maybe why
Tom Cruise movies don't have the impact
that they once did is that he is maybe
trying to play a young action star while
looking like a sexy uncle that is kind
of one of the things that are so
compelling about Watchmen it is
superheroes who have gotten older
superheroes who are kind of past their
prime superheroes who you know are in a
world that maybe doesn't need them
anymore and I think what better metaphor
for Tom Cruise's career so I think in
this one he would be playing his age he
would get to kick some ass which I think
he would you know like to do I think
that's in his contract yeah and I think
we would get to see another side of him
you know a side that maybe kind of
mirrors his career great Mike alright
again as jordan pointed out this is a
characters past his prime so we want
somebody who's done this type of thing
before and I'm of course talking about
Kevin Dillon from the hit TV show
entourage wonderful Jane's addiction's
yes
so porno for Pyro's maybe it might be
look we'll check that down I'll check
that yes okay we know Kevin Dillon as
Johnny Drama played a washed-up guy but
a guy who was in shape and can probably
kick some ass okay so we've seen him do
this thing before this is an
unconventional choice but we know he can
thrive on an HBO show Kevin Dillon for
the Nite Owl all right thank you sir
Sascha Perl raver what do you got well I
as much as I admire gymkata I would like
to see somebody who has karate moves I
would like to see somebody who is a
little sad sack very much past their
prime but who I want to see more of and
who I miss
and that person is John Cusack I want to
bring back John Cusack we saw him do
karate and say anything we know I want
to see him the boom box you realize how
happy
that was a gal blaster no authority oh I
think that he's got the sad sack
qualities he's got incredible pathos
he's an awesome actor but he's gotten
really soft and tragic and I think he
could bring all the characters or sorry
all the elements of the character
together in a really interesting way all
right Thank You Sasha all right so uh
these are man these are all interesting
choices you it seemed almost like a joke
answer but then you painted why Kevin
Dylan might thrive and that HBO habitats
a joke answer young man and John John
Cusack I you know I'm not sure about the
moves but I like the sad sack Tom Cruise
I love the idea of playing his age but
at the at the end of the day damn it if
I didn't like Sasha's answer the best
I'm going with John Cusack damn Earl
Scheib the pitch for Tom Cruise is very
strong tying into his character playing
someone who has passed this prime who
kind of has to look back on the fact
that he is not of the age that he should
be I thought that was a great pitch so
I'm going with Jordan Graham Cruz one
for Sasha one for Jordan Danielle what
do you like oh these were all great um
unfortunately there was stuff that I was
like I wish I would have seen more of
like with Jordan Tom Cruise I get that I
wish he would have also mentioned that
he has done the fat suit when he did
like Tropic Thunder yeah he has done
those things when he says Kevin Dillon
Venezia when he mentions guys in shape
and I was not in shape that's the kind
of thing about his characters and he's
coming back and he's not a dude that's
in shape yeah ding-dong um and so while
I do wish the Sasha would have brought
up Grosse Pointe blank um I still I have
to go with Sasha
all right Sasha she's got two of first
two picks first two victories for her
let's recast to the comedian Mike
Carlson John Travolta all right gadi I
just saw Gotti
and John Travolta it was a packed
theater for his Diwali
I am not joking I was sheared at the end
Burbank it was full I came late and I'm
worried I wasn't gonna get it people
were there people were excited the man
next to me was out of breath the whole
movie that's beside the point
yes John Travolta I want to see him to
sink his teeth into another meaty role
like the comedian I think that Travolta
will go the extra mile like he did with
Gotti I think he's gonna go out to the
comedy clubs I think I'm gonna see him
at the improv you can see the Laugh
Factory starting to do sets around town
and is my choice primarily to go see
John Travolta do stand-up at the Laugh
Factory and the improv yes I would like
to see that but I think he's gonna kill
it I think also he can play scary he can
play menacing and I think he can be a
great villain as evidenced by the great
film that I just saw with a full theater
all right a strange endorsement for
Gotti as in his argument for Travolta
Sasha I'm going Jon Hamm yeah who's like
a cigar chewing badass but also morally
reprehensible Don Draper but also
somebody who is so charismatic and so
intriguing that even though they're not
the primary center point of the
narrative even though it's primarily
done through flashback you want to go
back to that story over and over and
over again and if there's a well but I
will always return to its the Jon Hamm
well and also he looks a lot like
Jeffrey Dean Morgan who played a
comedian the first time around okay
great
Jordan who do you like well I mean I
mean I think the only choice to play the
comedian is Jeff Dunham and peanut the
Oh Jeff Dunham the Vegas comedian and
his racist devop it for a wrench the
ventriloquist the ventriloquist is so
you know a little left of center but I
mean I think something you know about
the comedian a reason why he's a
compelling character is that he is
two-faced he there's a side that he
presents to the world and then there was
a very very dark side that he presents
interpersonally and I think that you
know why not make that difference
physical a nice boring looking man and
his racist puppet friend so you know
when you know the public face of the
comedian when he's doing the publicity
photos and stuff like that Jeff Dunham a
nice man but behind the scenes when [ __ ]
gets
real that's when peanut comes out oh
okay
so we have Travolta John Hamm and Jeff
Dunham and peanut Daniel Radford um look
the Jetson I'm thing I think is really
interesting they don't thank you it was
that peanut is the murderer I just can't
and in a world where superheroes kind of
exist I can with the puppet being a
murderer but that is a really
interesting concept
Travolta had me but I I love your answer
but it can't be based on gaudy or us
both wanting to see him bit at laughs
factory which I do I do want to see him
if it pearl raves had me ham cigar
chewing Don Draper want to see him can
do the charisma but also do the darker
stuff had me gotta go with program okay
and I really loved Sasha's answer but
Travolta Jeff Dunham let's not forget
how to pain you on a stick but I'm gonna
go Travolta here I'm going Mike Carlson
with Travolta I thought he just his
overall career he mentioned that he can
play both and then he relied heavily on
gaudy but I think he strikes the like
the just the the figure that we of the
the comedian that we and imagine and him
going out and doing comedy I love that
Dan Merle Mike you relied so heavily on
God II know needed my vote and it
doesn't matter cuz I'd like that pick
the best anyway I also don't know John
Travolta I just think I think that Sasha
Jeff Dunham was fine but look at the
character I Sasha's pic was almost for
my mind too close to what we already
have and I'm more interesting I mean
I've got light Sasha but it turned me in
the other direction a little bit when
you said oh and he looks like Jeffrey
Dean Morgan that's not a selling we've
had
with the more interesting great so Mike
Carlson Gaudi fans I know you Merle I
see you yeah okay love me
alright and up next one of my favorite
all-time characters Rorschach back
around to Sasha who do you like for
Rorschach oh I like this a lot I like
Donald Glover don't cover who can
basically do everything and anything and
the thing about Rorschach is you want
somebody who can be deeply troubled but
you're still gonna root for the fact
that he's a vigilante that he's going
out against what's wrong but is also
like so damaged himself I feel like it's
the most extreme version of the
character he plays on Atlanta it's like
you're literally taking that just going
five million percent further and I think
that would be incredibly awesome and
also I just want to see Donald Glover
everything yes okay Donald Glover for
Rorschach Jordan Morris well if John
Travolta is playing the comedian why not
make this a faceoff reunion Nicholas
Cage I mean I don't know that I need to
explain that hard but I can make a case
this is a man who lives by his own code
this man who does things his own way
this is a man with a complicated set of
beliefs that he has trouble explaining
to the outside world
this is Nicolas Cage can you imagine
think about the caves delivery on those
classic Rorschach lines you're not in
here with me I [ __ ] that up
that's the I'm sorry I said the F word I
apologize so no the weddings yeah you're
right here with me I'm not in here with
you you out here with me and think about
him in the middle of a conversation
eating beans I think we all want to say
Nicholas Cage stop a conversation to eat
beans out of a can
he's the only choice I'm sorry for
saying the F word that's okay
no effing problem Mike Carlson alright I
think my answer is pretty obvious a lot
of people online are gonna say are
thinking in a reading before I say it
I'm thinking of an actor who is cranky
who's angry who's damaged who could play
a sort of a vigilante character like
this now this actor is no longer alive
so we will be taking pieces of his
dialogue from other things speaking it's
gather using a computer a sophisticated
computer and the per meters can do that
computers can do that I'm the actor I'm
talking about of course is William
Frawley from I Love Lucy
you played Fred Mertz who was a
notorious cranky tie I'm just gonna
knock you out for that it's just very
silly listen I'm making a judgment call
Wow
okay I'm gonna weigh in I love both of
these answers and I'm going Nick Cage
Danielle oh these answers are so amazing
I loved all of them they were all really
fun is actually I'm looking at his paper
his answer for dr. Manhattan is grumpy
cat sometimes you a caress um and I
appreciate and I love you Carlson Hobbes
and I also love proverbs answer but man
Jordan really had me when he was like
pictured Nick Cage eating beans and I
was like oh god I can't I can't picture
Nick Cage eating beans he is perfect
he's a great choice you made a great
argument I'm going toward takes that one
here we go
Mike I love you and you make me laugh
but uh sorry about that dr. Manhattan
Wow one of the most powerful great
characters and back around - uh oh no
where B Jordan Jordan so my choice for
dr. Manhattan is Orlando Bloom now how
did I come to this answer I was chatting
with a super producer Billy before the
show is that what we call him super
producer yeah Billy biz and I'm like my
choice for dr. Manhattan I should pick
someone who has blue in their name
that'd be funny and he said what about
Orlando Bloom and I said sure so it
started out as a pun but I think it is
actually a great choice think about
someone who is full of strength but also
is more internal than they are external
I mean that is you know why he was such
a great Legolas is because those you
know the elves are a race that has a
rich internal life but are kind of
monotone and hard to read on the outside
and I think that is part of what makes
dr. Manhattan such a great character is
that he is so clinical about everything
and is having this internal struggle
that doesn't exactly read on the outside
so Orlando blue
it'd be funny because blue is in his
name and dr. Manhattan is blue but also
he's the best choice
thank Jordan thank you Mike Carlson
brent Spiner from Star Trek The Next
Generation now dr. Manhattan is a cold
character he's very withdrawn and of
course data a very similar cursor now
brent Spiner is up there in age so what
we're gonna have to do is we're gonna
have to send a trainer over there and
get him on HGH but I think that a very
jacked
brent Spiner would be fantastic as dr.
Manhattan and no joke no one can argue
with me
that he'd be great paint that guy blue
yeah and give him an eight pack and he
would be fantastic as dr. Manhattan all
right thank you Mike Carlson Sasha pearl
raver well I thought Jordan was gonna
pick Orlando Bloom cause who's already
seen his penis
there's paddleboarding videos and
prosthetic my answer is I want to see it
resolved ah and it's interesting that
you bring up characters that are more
internal than external because I feel
like heimdal the character that plays in
Thor is very much somebody who also
could you want somebody who can see the
past the present in the future that's
very much what he is capable of also you
need somebody with an amazing voice I
could listen it yourself those voice all
day long you need somebody who already
has the 8-pack so we don't have to send
the HDH to Brett's brother's house
he's got eight twelve sixteen he's got a
keg it's but a good like ripped keg yeah
and also you need somebody who you want
to see like blue butt cheeks and I want
to see the blue butt cheeks of Idris
Elba walking around but more than
anything
you need somebody who is like the
nucleus center of this entire Magee yes
and that is what interest Elba is you
know what you got me with the words
McGee I'm giving it to Sasha and he
dressed Nova Danielle sorry it's my
first point because he can like Fred
spider you could just put him in a thing
he's great but you said the HDH so that
lost the argument oh god the bloom thing
was super great it was all really really
good and the the argument that you made
about the pun name is not
best um Sasha just has the best argument
this one I'm sorry like besides blue but
shakes which are not fair
but saying that you need someone who can
be the center of the nucleus in this
issue gagging all right Sasha you are
going to take this point because you
have an unsurmountable right now spider
justice for spider real quick real quick
so let's see everyone's casts here
there's Sasha's gal gadot would be all
right doctor oh yeah looking good
together Kathy Ireland Silk Spectre
Sasha gal gadot gal gadot here's Kim the
you know the Great and everything here I
love Carrie [ __ ] and she is amazing and
everything she does I loved her in the
leftover so I give you that point Jordan
but it is moot Sasha you take that point
it is - okay Tasha Pro Rehberg and made
it through our watchman casting all
right so it's - oh it's going to
question number three in the third round
here it is folks the trailer for the new
predator just dropped and it looks like
the new sequel features a super predator
pitch a sequel to a hit film that
features a more powerful super version
of the main character and this is
question number three so start with
player number three mr. Jordan Morris
thank you uh now my choice for a super
version of a pre-existing character is
super Superman now did this also start
out just because I thought that sounded
funny yes it did but I do think there is
a case to be made
the Superman problem is that you know
what can Superman fight that creates
some sort of suspense yeah you know he
is such an overpowered character that
you know it is hard to put something up
against him that that is it is not a
quick fight so I do
you need someone with his power set
anything you know there's a there's a
comic miniseries that I really like I
think it divided some fans this is Scott
Schneider Superman unchained 8 issues I
think it featured Superman fighting a
similarly powered version of himself
called wraiths and broke the power of
your Superman argument no thank you so
this is Superman fighting someone who is
just a little more it you know it's a
little stronger than himself and it was
the most suspense I have ever
experienced ingesting any sort of
Superman media because you really
thought that he could lose so yeah I
think I think a super Superman is the
way to go all right Thank You Jordan
background to Mike Carlson alright I'm
gonna take a beloved trilogy that's been
hasn't had a movie in a while and we're
gonna bring it back and we're gonna give
it the old super the old super thing I'm
talking about super Austin Powers okay
we all remember Austin Powers he's
coming back Mike Meyers been talking
about it how about this for a tagline
Austin gets real powers yeah yeah baby
all the gags are bigger alright I'll be
all the pooping gags behind like a
dressing area those are bigger super
powers he can fly now he's Randy or okay
Randy or it's funny or it's bigger whets
we have to go bigger with Austin Powers
now are all of his side characters also
going to be super of course they are
super Goldmember super dr. evil super
Scott evil alright this is going to
bring Austin Powers back in a big bad
way it's also going to be a send-up of
the superhero genre because Mike Meyers
is very good at parody okay super Austin
Powers is gonna start a new trilogy and
everyone's going to love it alright
super Austin Powers Sasha Pearl raver
alright this one is very close to my
heart we're gonna do the super greatest
showmen we are gonna take the two things
that Hugh Jackman loves most look at
that face he is so happy because he is
gonna sing and he is gonna dance but now
we're gonna take the other thing that he
is exceptional at which is being an
action hero and he is going to take that
and sing and dance about it it's going
to be everything that we want from him
the incredible physicality that he
brought with Logan and now that we know
he's not gonna be an x-man anymore he
can go do marvelous crazy magical circus
musical stuff as a superhero and Zac
Efron on his flying trapeze and bringing
in another superhero
zendaya and they can do all kinds of
super circus craziness with their
incredible super
Sasha you are so excited fight it out
everybody right and no one wants to see
the greatest showman be super because
the first movie is very boring weeks ago
I could remember a psycho song right now
and I went to a sing-along this weekend
and it was off the charts
it was jumped off at the building I was
on because it was so happy I wanted to
imitate Michelle Williams you are wrong
you can't do Austin towers without
furniture Eyre our EP the first movie
doesn't have Verne Troyer and it's the
best one okay so of course to succumb to
singing yes please
a Justice League of Mike Myers
characters super Shrek yes and yes so
elated an axe murderer gets pregnant oh
boy don't forget a super love too
tires dude the gong show the love I need
more of the my crier like my Randy Mark
Myers we don't want any of that Jordan
are you throwing your support over to my
seems like this culminates in a shared
Mike Myers of might be Tara super Steve
Rubell from Studio 15 villain is a is a
it's like an evil Suicide Squad of Dana
Carvey Carrie oh my god and the church
lady Lex Luthor this I was going with
all of this yes the last movie in the
toys he brought Lex Luthor up so I'm
actually gonna go back to the real topic
which is super Superman yeah we've seen
Superman lose that was how remember he I
don't wanna spoil stuff because people
yell at me what we've seen Superman
that's like I'm just saying yeah no sir
I know and you're right it's like we
never see him have anybody who the
powers actually seem like it's going to
be a real battle but that's always sort
of the conceit anyway so I feel like
we've seen a super Superman and that's
what we saw with the last Justice League
movie and nobody wants Boston powers but
don't you want to see Hugh Jackman lit
his greatest dreams doing both of the
things that he's the most you want to
see him sing and dance as you know to
Toby he does hostess roadies it yeah
that's what it's there for
the Tonys is there so Hugh Jackman can
get it Yaya's out
goodbye it is too great you this is wish
for you German Jordan yeah you haven't
spoken much about the super Superman in
a few minutes sure are you gonna abandon
ship on that and go hey I think III will
disagree that we've seen it I mean I
think the closest thing we've got on
film is is when he has fought Zod in
both Superman 2 and in Man of Steel and
when you're fighting a similarly powered
villain but I think in both cases it it
was never a you were never concerned
that he was gonna lose because you know
as you know as cool as odds powers can
be it never seemed like he was greater
than Superman and I think I don't know I
think that would that would be kind of
cool at seeing Superman but a little bit
more and I think that would really juice
a sequel I think that making it slightly
different version is what Jordan is
pitching just like slightly you keep
saying like little Dan any sexualities
no actualities to check no okay no it's
pretty pretty theoretical we're pretty
on point I think that super versions of
characters and whatnot so you know I
think Sasha made a compelling argument
about combining the things Hugh Jackman
loves but you are way more excited than
I think anyone else in the room and you
know Jordan I think you undercut your
art I bailed on my little eye
I'm eating the picture that like you
know we kind of saw it and Mike pointed
out Mike really ding just saying it was
just a little bit better also I was
nervous for Superman who's got not just
going cansada but there were two other
baddies with his powers yeah I'm in
Superman underrated I'm choosy yeah it's
good stuff but yeah like you and Mike
combining to paint that Justice League
of Mike Meyers characters alright
fantastic yeah I mean that took me on a
flight of fancy Mike you got my point
for that dan Merle I I have to say that
I I like Sasha's enthusiasm but I think
that she was hit a little bit too much
by it's just like aren't you just
describing Hugh Jackman yeah and who he
actually is as a person and I agree I
think that Jordans fault lay and mostly
that the argument was based on the crux
of I would be worried about Superman
losing to somebody and I have the
nuclear man and he literally did fight
himself in Superman 3 and only one of
those options gave birth at this very
table to a cinematic universe of pop
ranch eyes I am also going to have to go
with Mike with the even Randhir super
awesome what everybody think okay so
going into the poll this is what the
numbers are as of right now sequel with
super version of a main character we
have Austin Powers super Austin Powers
was 70%
Wow 70 Wow
17:17 50% is super Superman and 9% wait
music or noise showman everybody is very
anti Hugh Jackman today Q I got trying
to let me I'm gonna look at what we've
got going on
super Pennywise was something Michaela
yeah that that seems terrifying does he
just work I don't understand you guys
want from from a super penny wise
someone super bond that's going mr.
James Bond the Q has some sort of serum
he's like now we've we've been
developing this yeah could kill you bond
but it's that's cool anyway up and then
on Twitter at Eric with a CE underscore
ba CH e LDR said super Beetlejuice lots
of fun super characters hey all the
finals are sad we're going to the speed
round okay it is going to be Mike
Carlson with one point going up against
Sascha Pro raver with two points Jordan
you fought admirably I might come to you
for some thoughts or opinions during
this speed rounds be over here messing
around on my phone yeah return some
emails we'll get back to you alright
let's so here's how the speed round
works
I will pose the question first person to
answer will get to go first and
elaborate on their answer and it's 20
seconds 20 seconds and then rebuttals of
10 seconds 10 seconds are you ready
folks
yes all right let's do this question
number one of the speed round oh and by
the way uh Dan myself and now Danielle
with her own opinions just like in the
Watchmen round will be chiming in no
time for a Twitter for a YouTube poll in
the speed round okay question one solo
screenwriter Jonathan Kasdan will write
Indiana Jones 5 which would you rather
see solo 2 or indiana jones indiana
jones 5 ok solo 2 indiana jones 5 you
answer first sacha 20 seconds begin when
you speak solo 2 is already done it's
Lando and all I want is Donald Glover
the entire time as Lando Calrissian we
do not eat anywhere Indiana Jones we
already bombed the fridge it's
completely destroyed do not bring Shia
LaBeouf back it's horrendous we need to
fix the solo problem in the way
fix the solar problem is Lando and
Chewbacca and that's the party I want to
RSVP to nobody needs to see solo can't
have a different lead character than Han
Solo it has to be Han Solo you have to
figure that out so we can't pitch it as
that indian drones 5 at least there's a
chance that we can do something with it
solo is just full of references to how
he got like his shirt and his pants like
we don't need any of that
Indiana Jones 5 at least there's a fresh
shot of continuing the mythology as
opposed to just like shrinking it and
making it feel small shrinking and
making you feel solid you want to see
the island take off like a spaceship
again and solo two's title is Lando solo
the way you wanted him the first time
around that's how you fix that problem
buddy there's there's three great
Indiana Jones movies and there's one
okay one there's only one bad solo movie
right now so there's a lot more to work
with and with the play with Han Solo
excuse me Indiana Jones can be played by
Harrison Ford I'm barnburner
Daniel Radford what yeah wow this was
really great
oh these arguments are so amazing and as
much as I love the argument that like
solo with Glover and Glover and Chewie I
do want to see that movie but Carlson
had me with the you know you can you can
continue on it doesn't shrink it and as
much as it gets to expand the franchise
and you can still have Harrison Ford so
he doesn't want to do that movie anymore
all right I feel like the tooth the two
arguments Sascha's was facing backwards
I thought mics was facing forwards which
helps me on suicide and also it doesn't
help to advocate for a movie that does
not star the lead character that was
asked about so I also have to go with my
okay we're locked up at 2:00 to Jordan
which one did you like better you know I
just in general I would like to see the
other indie movie just because I think
at this point in time might be cool to
have a movie where the main characters
main thing is punching Nazis yeah we
could all you gonna use a little bit of
the sure thing sure thing
Sasha for the record I like your answer
but that is moot we have to to go into
question number two again question
number two of the speed round Top Gun 2
is looking to casting the son of goose
who should it be
Castle son of goose I mean 5 can valve
cover and just play his own size that's
nice like oh that's Iceman's alright 5
tide sheridan f run Oh run that is cold
as ice Sharon that is cold
Zac Ephron not nora ephron right ok hi
Sharon vs. Zac Efron Sasha you smoke
first 20 seconds begin whenever you
speak now ok the thing about Top Gun is
it's an incredible action movie but
there's no heart the harder that movie
comes spoiler alert when goose dies so
you need somebody who can bring pathos
and the pain of having lost his father
and been raised by a mourning meg Ryan
and ty Sheridan is incredibly emotional
he's really deep he's super cute so you
get like the adorableness but he's a
really great actor like widow did what
he SACA from because look we need
somebody cute and this is a cutest man
as far as age wise we go
but we also need somebody that seems
like he would fit effortlessly into the
original Top Gun this is a beefcake
we're talking about you can see Zac
Efron playing volleyball on the beach
number one is the aesthetic with Top Gun
yeah sure there's a little heart in it
but we need it to look like the original
and feel like the original and Zac Efron
is a type of factor than him bodies but
then that's exactly why you need the ty
Sheridan because he wasn't a beefcake on
the beach goose was the dorky one he was
the nerd he was the guy in like the
Hawaiian shirt who didn't really fit in
and that's why he died because he wasn't
like man and after
finishing but zac efron can play that
okay he's in a bunch of movies where he
looks stupid over and over again so he
is handsome he fits the aesthetic but he
can also look silly he can also be a
same similar type of character but also
I think he's a different type of
character to the answers but you know
what Sasha sent you really with her
rebuttal Sasha takes the point in my
book dan Merle I well first of all
there's there's a there's an oversight
here that happened on-screen Shakey's
news yesterday was that what speaking of
the son of goose Noah has spoken of Ryan
Gosling which would make the most you
know i Mike I thought had it when he's
just like he's going into the Lord he's
going back to the original but yes the
volleyball scene goose had his shirt on
he was not greased up playing to Kenny
Loggins and so I think Sasha spiked it
and I am also gonna go with side there
you go Sasha you take that point thank
you
it is three two Sasha over Mike this is
game point you need this to keep the
game going Sasha you need this to finish
him if it's alright um I just drooled on
myself when I said finishes all right
here we go question number three of the
speed round some of this year's
Universal Halloween mazes at Universal
Hollywood Horror Nights will be based on
Chucky and killer clowns from outer
space what movie would make the most
terrifying Halloween maze The Shining
[Music]
Pan's Labyrinth okay we have Pan's
Labyrinth and The Shining Sashi you
spoke first 20 seconds begin whatever
you speak now imagine this you're
setting it up exactly like the hotel
you're going through the process you're
but you don't know what corner you're
gonna turn and there's gonna be an old
lady jumping out of a bathtub you don't
know where the kids are coming from you
don't know where the elevator of blood
is gonna open and unleash it is the
scariest movie ever made and it's the
simplicity of it and just imagine Jack
Nicholson coming at you with an axe and
you don't know where that's it just pops
out of nowhere all right I want
something that's very claustrophobic
that the scenes in Pan's Labyrinth with
a crazy man with the weird eyes at the
dinner table with all the food that is
gonna be claustrophobic and terrifying
and also uses the outs of the creativity
of the different Imagineers or the
universal creative people they're gonna
have to do something very impressive
that's not only scary but visually
amazing this is just sort of a hotel and
a guy with an ex you're gonna have to
see the full gear Motel movie magic
everything you're talking about is about
creating something that is otherworldly
and the thing about The Shining that
makes it so terrifying is that it's so
tangible every time you check into a
hotel do you check that bathtub and
you're afraid that you're gonna hear
Redrum in your sleep but in a theme park
I want to be impressed I'm of air I have
a podcast called podcast to ride and we
love creativity we love it when
something is done that is amazing not
just something that's just scare for
scare sake we want something that shows
the human imagination off alright Wow
nicely done gang a plug for your podcast
in there my just yes slipping into that
question there and check out his podcast
but the question was the most terrifying
maze and Sasha absolutely made the case
for that I go with Sasha Danielle oh you
know if we're going with terrifying and
not just like a carnival ride it has to
be Sasha programs raves
I appreciate like how good that would be
as a carnival ride it's terrifying I
will get it I will be Ruth Bader
Ginsberg and I will descent okay that's
a great counter-argument thank you it
was it was a great answer but Sasha
[Applause]
the Jack and Jill Sandler will appear
dunkaccino Sasha Wow yeah I had a baby
you came back to movie fights and yeah
tuck it homes very exciting thank you
guys so much for having you that was
awesome
go ahead and plug some stuff yeah if you
guys want to follow me on Twitter
Instagram I'm at Sasha Pearl River I'm
on FX movie download where every Friday
at 8 o'clock I did a little fun for
screen junkies that will be I don't know
when but eventually and I just love
seeing you guys it's so great to be back
excellent oh you brought it well played
Jordan Morris this your first time on
movie Phi this is my first movie fight
super funny great answers go please go
ahead and tell us where we can find you
sure I'm at Jordan underscore Morris on
Twitter and if check out bubble wherever
you get your podcasts something I did
with the great Danielle Radford you'll
hear her voice you'll hear some jokes
that she wrote it's a great time bubble
wherever you get your podcast and it's
fiction and it's fiction yeah awesome
thanks Jordan thanks for mean everybody
Mike Carlson always great to have you
thanks for coming and making us laugh
making us shrink I try to do sad Carlson
no it says it on the screen that's my
Twitter and of course my podcast pot app
it's podcast the ride
it's about theme parks we just had Jeff
Garlin on he was talking about an old
ride called f-u-n wings and we have a
lot of fun silly stuff if you like rides
and the theme parks so and Jordan is
gonna be on in a few yeah or about the
Waterworld stunt show yes Kevin Costner
versus the smokers what's going on buddy
see uh you don't have any movies this
weekend sorry Oh tonight and I might
check out uncle drew sign up for the AMC
thing so you know I got to start using
it get my money's worth
yeah I did go through the shining lives
at Horror Nights last year and it was
quite terrifying yeah and also I leave
you with this picture
Chuck Norrises the crotch shot showing
how how effective they can be packaged
[Music]
80 and Chuck Norris have beefed now
Daniel Radford thank you as always you
can find me on Instagram Danielle
underscore Radford you can find me on
Twitter you can also find me every
Thursday morning I'm doing something
called raise up on a gamma ray it's like
9:30 a.m. so you can literally watch
that Pacific say no time and then watch
and then switch over to s Ju it's so
easy and we're doing something called
throwback Thursdays where I take someone
through the history of when they first
discovered all the nerdy stuff they like
and how it like shaped them into the
nerd that they became no it's great I
again if I wasn't on this I would this
would be my favorite podcast like I'm
not even like very cool Danielle thank
you for holding it down on the social
media and in life appreciate you and I
want to thank you guys for watching
please hit me up on Twitter and
Instagram at Hal Rudnick and I want to
give a shout out to Austin Cleese and
Marco Carlson on Instagram for giving me
the best answers I've asked some movie
fights questions on Instagram this week
I asked better movie Back to the Future
or Ferris Bueller's Day Off and it got
heated so check that out on Instagram
the best answers came from those two I
shout it out and thank you for watching
any thanks everybody thanks Billy biz
thanks JT
and see you next time bye bye
[Music]
you